إليزابيث ، دعونا نتعمق في التفاصيل
حول ما توصلت إليه هذه الدراسة الكبيرة ،
أخبرني عن هذه الزيادات في مخاطر
كل من الموت ومشاكل القلب ، حسنًا
بريانا ، دعنا ننتقل إلى هذه
الأرقام ، هذه دراسة قادها
أشخاص في هارفارد ونشرت في
The  لانسيت اليوم فقط نظروا إلى ستة
مرضى في ستمائة وواحد وسبعين
مستشفى ، لذلك تم نقل هؤلاء المرضى إلى المستشفى
- مرضى فيروس كورونا العذر في ست
قارات ، ما يقرب من 15000 من هؤلاء
المرضى يتلقون هيدروكسي كلوروكوين أو
الكلوروكين في كثير من الأحيان مع
أدوية أخرى ، ما وجدوه هو
أولئك الذين  كانوا يتعاطون هيدروكسي كلوروكوين
أو كلوروكين بنسبة 33 إلى 45 في المائة
أكثر عرضة للوفاة حتى بعد
تعديلهم بسبب وجود بعض
الاختلافات بين المرضى الذين لم
يتناولوا الدواء والذين كانوا يتناولون
الأدوية ومجموعة المراقبة التي لم تكن
أيضًا هي التي تتناول الأدوية  كانوا
بين نقطتين وأربع وخمس مرات
أكثر عرضة للإصابة باضطراب نظم القلب
، أعني الطبيب 33  ما هو
احتمال وفاة إليزابيث بنسبة 45 في المائة ،
فهذه أرقام مذهلة ، ومع ذلك فقد
تضاعفت مبيعات هيدروكسي كلوروكين في مارس ، لذا فأنا من يصف
هذه الأدوية جيدًا ، فأنا لا أعرف من
الذي يصفها وهذه
هي الأم  من بين جميع الدراسات في الوقت الحالي
، تمت متابعة 96 ألف مريض
منذ أن نظروا إلى المخططات الخاصة بهم
من ديسمبر الماضي إلى أبريل ،
اسمحوا لي أن أصفها بهذه الطريقة كان الناس مرضى
في البداية إذا لم تتناول أيًا من
هذه الأدوية ، وتسعة بالمائة من
مات الناس إذا تناولت مزيجًا
من هيدروكسي كلوروكين ومضاد حيوي
25 في المائة ماتوا أي ثلاث مرات أكثر من
الناس ماتوا ذهبوا على هذا الدواء في
أوقات يائسة بدأ بعض الناس في فعل
أشياء يائسة وهذا هو الأمر الخطير جدًا لدرجة
أن رئيس
الولايات المتحدة هو  قول مرحبًا ، هذا
ليس جيدًا ، إنه شيء وهو
شيء خطير جدًا وفوق
كل ذلك ، إذا لم يتم اتباعه بشكل صحيح ،
فلديك ما يقرب من عشرة ر  فرصة أكبر
للإصابة باضطراب ضربات القلب ، هذا
الدواء يمكن أن يطيل هيدروكسي كلوروكين
من الوقت
الذي تتواصل فيه غرف القلب
مع بعضها البعض ويمكن أن يكون لديك
كل عدم انتظام ضربات القلب ، لذلك إذا
أراد الناس إثبات أن هناك بالفعل
دليل على أن هيدروكسي كلوروكين لا
يساعد في  فيروس مشفر والآن
هناك دليل على أنه ليس فقط لا يساعد
ولكن عندما تكون مريضًا حقًا
يكون الأمر مهددًا للحياة وفترة خطيرة
من الصعب الحصول
على تشخيص بالسرطان ناهيك عن الوباء
وقد أدرك الأطباء أن بعض
المرضى لن يفعلوا ذلك.  لا أشعر بالراحة عند
الذهاب إلى المستشفى ، ولذا
اكتشف الأطباء هنا في الطيف
طريقة إبداعية للمرضى للحصول على ما يحتاجون إليه
دون مغادرة سيارتهم أبدًا
عندما يكون علاج السرطان هو
السبيل الوحيد للمضي قدمًا ، ولا توجد فكرة أنه من
المحتمل أن يكون الأمر كذلك.  لقد كانت حالة
سرطانية
تم تشخيص حالة جوديث بأكملها بسرطان المبيض
في فبراير وتم اكتشافها مبكرًا في المرحلة
الأولى ، شكرًا جزيلاً
فول ممتنة للغاية جوديث تخضع للعلاج الكيميائي الذي تحصل عليه في المستشفى ، لكن أربع عمليات متابعة إضافية مثل إغلاق ذراعها المقرر يوم الجمعة لتعزيز خلايا الدم البيضاء ، كانت خيارًا آخر لزيادة الرعاية هو الشيء الصحيح الذي يجب القيام به للمرضى في هذا وقت الوباء تقول ميليسا هيغدن مع الطيف إن كل ما هو مطلوب لخدمات الأورام الروتينية مخبأ داخل محطة العمل المتنقلة هذه في p2 في أقرب مرآب للسيارات ، فإن المعدات تعني أن المرضى لا يزالون بحاجة إلى ترك سياراتهم لأولئك الذين قد يكونون متوترين من التعاقد مع covin 19 ، الشيء المهم هو لحماية مرضانا من السرطان من أي شيء يمكن أن يضرهم وعندما لا يكون لديك جهاز مناعي وتتلقى العلاج الكيميائي وينشأ جائحة ، يمكنك حتى تخيل الضغط الذي قد يسبب لك العلاج الكيميائي ، لذلك نحن فقط كان علينا أن نجعل ذلك يحدث بالنسبة لجوديث ، فهذا يساعد حقًا عندما لا تستطيع عائلتها القدوم إلى المستشفى والعلاج الكيماوي يجعل المشي صعبًا.  أو
حدث لي أن انسحبت هنا ، فأنت تعلم حتى الآن أن
حوالي 20 مريضًا قد جربوا ذلك ،
اعتقد القليل منهم أننا مجانين وقالوا إنني
لم أسمع أبدًا بأي شيء كهذا ،
ولكن إذا كنت على استعداد لتجربته
و  أولئك الذين استخدموه قد
أحبوه حقًا ،
لدى جوديث جلسة علاج كيميائي واحدة فقط
لتتوافق مع لقطة أخرى في
مركز القيادة وتأمل أن جميع
الخطوات التي اتخذتها الآن ستعطيها
أخبارًا سارة في وقت متأخر ،
إنه تقرير عن خصائص
كان أول الأشخاص الذين تم اختبار
إصابتهم بالفيروس التاجي داخل الكلية الملكية
للممارسين العامين ، وهي
منظمة مهنية للأطباء في
المملكة المتحدة ، نُشرت في مجلة The Lancet
Infectious Diseases Journal التي تضم 3800
شخصًا ، قال الباحثون إن ما يقرب من 600
شخص إيجابي لانتشار الفيروس التاجي
كان أقل من 5  النسبة
المئوية للمرضى الذين تقل أعمارهم عن 18 عامًا ولكن ما يقرب من
أربعة أضعاف في الأشخاص الذين
يبلغون من العمر 40 عامًا أو
أكبر يقولون إن خطر الإصابة كان
أعلى بين الرجال منه لدى النساء في
المرضى السود  أكثر من البيض وفي الأشخاص الذين
يعانون من السمنة مقارنة بأولئك الذين يتمتعون بوزن صحي
، يقولون إن العدوى كانت أعلى أيضًا في
أولئك الذين يعيشون والأكثر حرمانًا أو
المناطق الحضرية ، لكنهم يقولون إن حجم الأسرة
لا يبدو أنه يؤثر بشكل كبير على
خطر الإصابة بين أولئك الذين يعانون
من مرضين مزمنين أو أكثر  الأمراض في
نفس الوقت فقط أولئك الذين يعانون من
مرض الكلى المزمن لديهم مخاطر متزايدة للإصابة
بالعدوى في حين أن الخطر لدى
المدخنين النشطين كان حوالي النصف الذي لوحظ في
أولئك الذين لم يدخنوا أبدًا في
اللحظة الصحية الحالية ، أنا ماندي
جاثر أضعهم فيها ويجب أن أفرك  كل ذلك
معًا بالإضافة إلى هذا اللون الأصفر الملون
عبارة عن مزيج من الفازلين
ومحلول الفلورسنت تحت
ضوء الأشعة فوق البنفسجية ، وهذا سوف
يتوهج جيدًا وسيحاكي
الجراثيم على يدي بشكل صحيح ، لذلك سيحاكي هذا
الاتصال وانتشار الاتصال الذي تعرفه
منك إلى أشياء أخرى  أن تلمسها
وقد يلمسها شخص آخر د.
باتريك هيوز هو طبيب الطوارئ الذي
يشرف على
برنامج محاكاة طب الطوارئ في جامعة فلوريدا أتلانتيك ،
وقد دعانا لتناول الغداء وقام
بتعيين ما يسمى الموزع حتى
نتمكن من رؤية كيف يمكن للجراثيم الموجودة على يدي والتي
يمكن أن تكون قطرات فيروس كورونا أن
تنتشر في مطعم في مطعمنا
الجدول نحافظ على أقنعةنا لحماية
أنفسنا وبعضنا البعض ، أسكب الماء
للجميع على الطاولة
وأمرر الطعام متسائلاً عما إذا كنت
أتجول حول الفيروس أيضًا ، فنحن أيضًا نشارك
الملح والفلفل ، فقد حان الوقت لتشغيل
الأشعة فوق البنفسجية  أضواء لرؤية ما
ربما أنشرته ، تذكر أنني كنت الشخص الوحيد الذي كان
يحمل ما يمكن أن يكون الفيروس
في يدي ، لم يكن لديك أي جراثيم ،
كنت الموزع ، لذلك عندما تنظر
إلى يدي وتنظر إلى كيفية انتقاله
إلى  البعض منكم فقط من خلال مشاركة العناصر
على الطاولة أو سكين في هذه الحالة أو
كوب ماء ، أعني أنه لا يتطلب الأمر سوى
القليل من الصواب لجعل شخص آخر
مريضًا ، ماذا عن وعاء الرقائق الذي
مررت به حولك  يمكنك أن ترى أين
لمست حافة الوعاء لتمريرها
حول الجراثيم المحاكاة التي تعرف أنها
عالقة على السطح تمامًا مع
هزازات الملح والفلفل
وإبريق الماء كان هناك اتصال منتشر على
الكؤوس والقوائم أيضًا حتى غدائي  الأصدقاء ،
هذا هو المكان الذي عندما جاءت راندي
لتناول الغداء مع أصدقائها
لمست كتفها مباشرة
لتحية الجميع ويمكنك أن ترى
الخطوط العريضة لكفها تطبع بصمة يدها
مباشرة في العرض ،
إنه أمر مخيف جدًا أن كمية
الانتشار  يمكن لشخص واحد أن يكون في غرفة كهذه ،
ونريد أيضًا أن نرى ما
سيحدث إذا كنت بالخارج لتناول طعام الغداء أو العشاء
مع صديق أو عائلتك في
مطعم وسعل شخص ما ، لذا دعنا
نرفع الأنوار ودعنا نرى
المشكلة هناك  كانت الآن المزيد من القطرات
على وعاء الرقائق والقوائم
وإبريق الماء - انظر ماذا
حدث للشوكة بعد ذلك السعال المحاكي ،
فهذه ستكون جراثيم حقيقية إذا كان ذلك
سعالًا حقيقيًا على الشوكة كنت
سألتقط f  لم تكن قادرة على رؤية
تلك الجراثيم بالعين المجردة حتى
المرأة التي تجلس على يميني على بعد عدة
أقدام من عارضة أزياء السعال كانت بها
قطرات على وجهها ، يمكنك رؤيتها على
وجهها نظارتها قناعها لم تكن
ترتدي قناعًا  كانت
ستتنفسه بشكل صحيح